A scene of falling stars looks amazing
and we all love to see it !
What are these falling stars?
They are meteoroids or similar bodies from space,
which enter the earth’s atmosphere.
However, this wasn’t known to people back in time.
People innocently believed that actual stars from space
fall down on the earth’s surface.
It was due to advancements in science and technology
that many discoveries were made, and the fact
that these are not stars but meteoroids was accepted!
Same is applicable to many legendary discoveries
of the past.
Due to several reasons,
many discoveries were left ignored and unaccepted.
But the advancement in technology
helped in better research which could support the long
ignored works of many scientists!
One example of such unfortunate incidences
was the work of the father of Genetics, Gregor Mendel !
Mendel’s work was far beyond excellence!
However, it wasn’t appreciated right from the time
it was put forth before the scientific society.
Several reasons led to the demotivating rejection
of his efforts!
One of the major reasons, included his concept
of “non-blending” inheritance .
According to Mendel, genes or FACTORS to be precise,
do not blend and that the phenotype of offsprings
is similar to only one parent.
It cannot be an intermediate between the two parents.
However, the variations seen in organisms in general
could not be explained by this concept
of non-blending of characters!
Secondly, Mendel introduced mathematical calculations
to explain biological processes.
He presented results in the form of ratios.
At that time, mathematical forms of biological results
were not easily accepted.
Hence, his work was largely ignored.
Lastly, when Mendel said that there are factors
which are passed from one generation to the other,
he had no physical proof of those units.
In the sense, there was no evidence of the
physical form of the factors that Mendel could present.
So the proposition, that discrete units called FACTORS
exists, was like a hypothetical theory.
Mendel had no proper evidence
that such units actually exist.
Due to all these reasons, Mendelian genetics remained
dormant for several years.
After being almost rejected in the mid 1860’s
Mendel’s work remained unnoticed until the
beginning of 20th century.
So what exactly happened in the early 1900s?
Who shined a light on the remarkable contributions
of Gregor Mendel?
Let us find that out in the next part!
Microscopes ease the lives of scientists.
However, they are not new inventions.
Microscopes were invented several years ago.
Beginning with simple lenses used to zoom in the
desired structures, today, we have electron microscopes,
which can give us minute details
of the smallest possible structure!
But the microscopes in the nineteenth century
were not that advanced.
So minute observations of the living cells
and the cellular components were not really possible.
In the beginning of the twentieth century,
the advancements in microscopy
and related techniques helped
in acute observations of the cell division processes.
As a result, cytologists could now figure out structures
that duplicate and divide during cell division .
Which structures could these be ?
That’s right !
Scientists were now able to identify
and spot chromosomes inside the nucleus.
We now know what chromosomes are
and how they look.
But it wasn’t known back then.
So the newly found structures inside the cell
grabbed a lot of attention.
Also, by this time, due to the
understanding of the chromosomal structures,
processes like mitosis
and meiosis were well understood.
During the same time, Mendel’s long ignored
legendary work started gaining importance
as many scientists started re-evaluating the results.
There were two scientists, from different parts of the
globe, who simultaneously put forth a few hypotheses.
These hypotheses, became a theory later,
which is what we are going to study now.
Walter Sutton, an American geneticist and physician,
was working on grasshoppers.
He found that chromosomes occur in pairs
and during meiosis, separate from one another
in the gametes formed.
He put forth the assumption that a pair of chromosome
contains one chromosome from mother
and one from the father.
The separation of chromosomes during meiosis may be
the explanation of the Mendelian laws of inheritance.
This is what Sutton hypothesised.
Around the same time, a German biologist named
Theodor Boveri was working on sea urchins.
He found that in order to have a proper
embryonic development, all the chromosomal pairs
have to be present in the embryo.
Both these works later were combined to give us a
single theory which came to be known as the
Boveri-Sutton theory of inheritance.
Now, it is also referred to as the
“Chromosomal Theory of Inheritance”.
The theory, in simple words stated that
“individual genes are found at specific locations
on a particular chromosome.
Also, the pattern of behaviour of the chromosomes
during meiosis explains us the Mendelian laws,
as to why and how genes are inherited .”
The theory and thus the laws of genetics
can be explained well with the help of exactly
three points or observations !
The first point said that chromosomes come in pairs.
These are now called homologous pairs by us !
One chromosome from the pair comes from the mother
while the other from the father.
Isn’t this what even Mendel hypothesised about genes ?
He said that “factors”, now called genes, come in pairs.
One factor of the pair is from the mother
and the other from the father.
The next point stated
that the chromosomes from a single pair
separate from each other during the process of meiosis.
That means, one chromosome
will be passed to the respective gamete.
This is just the simplest explanation of Mendel’s law
of segregation.
In the law, Mendel emphasised on the
separation of factors that is alleles into gametes.
The last observation of the theory states that
different chromosomes assort into gametes
independent of each other during meiosis.
This is what even Mendel had said
in his law of independent assortment.
The alleles of the different genes assort
independent of each other during gamete formation.
This is how the Chromosomal theory of inheritance
helps us understand
that the genes are present on chromosomes.
And also that the are the units of heredity !
This is how the theory supported Mendel’s work
and was useful in proving the Laws of genetics
put forth by Mendel.
However,
now the question is how was this theory accepted?
What results were presented to prove this theory right
and acceptable?
A few years later, another legendary scientist
named Thomas Hunt Morgan,
carried out a few experiments on the little fruit fly,
Drosophila melanogaster.
His experiments confirmed Sutton
and Boveri’s theory further.
With all these,
Mendel’s long ignored work gained recognition
and the remarkable laws of Genetics were accepted!